- Hey guys, if you bought
one of my sneakers,
I want you to buy one of my wines.
(laughing)
That was amazing.
(intense music)
- Yeah!
- You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Back up.
(upbeat electronic music)
Why don't you guys both come in,
we'll go make some content for ads.
Illinois, your Bulls just got
my homie, Carmelo Anthony,
scroll it up, Babbin, scroll it up.
He's on your team and I
wanna be on your wine team.
One of the things you
(laughs)
Nate, come on, you gotta hold it together.
I'm in a silly mood today.
(laughing)
Those transitions are the best.
Put that in the vlog,
when you get a chance.
All right.
- Yeah but I'm a Jersey cat, I don't care.
Illinois.
Buy my wines.
Or I'll send Nate after you.
I wanna go live and sell some wine.
Let's go live.
(slow electronic music)
- [Female Voice On Phone]
Do you remember me?
- I can't see you.
- [Female] What?
- There we go.
- [Female] Do you remember me?
- Not yet but keep going.
Help me remember.
- [Female] We've met twice
- Okay
- [Female] With me and my
boyfriend on your Instagram
- Oh yeah I do remember that.
- [Female] I think that the
biggest question I wanted
to ask you was like, something
I struggled with a lot
is self doubt, you know
- From the parents
- [Female] Not just that,
but I'm critical of myself.
Like a lot of it
- No you don't, this is
the number one mistake
that everybody thinks.
Everybody thinks that they
put their own self doubt
on themselves, it's
actually not how it works.
Outside forces got into your head
and then made you self doubt.
You think it's your voice.
Nobody's voice hates
them in the beginning.
It's a voice that's been
implanted in you either in the
beginning from your
neighborhood and outside force,
often parents, and so
where people get really
fucked up is they think
like when I talk about
don't listen to the
Jones's they're like fuck
you know, I don't care about other people,
it's that I shit on myself
and I'm trying to get
people to understand you're
not shitting on yourself,
you've taken on the voice of
somebody from the outside.
- [Female] Right.
- You weren't born with like I hate me.
You've taken on the voice of
somebody from the outside.
It's very important that
you understand this.
I'll tell you why.
It gets a lot easier if
you actually believe it
and understand it because
then you can understand it
versus laying there and being
like why do I hate myself?
You know what I mean?
- [Female] Right.
- You don't
somebody implanted their
insecurities on you.
It's why a lot of people
get value out of me because
through my practical optimism,
not my delusional you're an
eighth place trophy, but
from my practical optimism.
If people keep putting
that voice in their ears,
the reason people listen
to so much of my content
is I'm optimistic but I'm
not going to sugar coat it
and be like if you just
wish it, it happens.
And in that balance over
time, if that's what goes
into your ears, then all of a
sudden you start believing it
like I genuinely believe it.
I believe that the two of us
should never doubt ourselves.
Why?
Like I don't understand.
Like go do and deal with the
I think I suck at most things
but I need to go find that
out for myself not not
do it because I'm worried
about somebody judging me on my failure.
Like, this is just the way it is.
I just, I'm just, really
happy that we're interacting
this much because like
honestly, you know it's funny,
I just want people to listen
to me as much as possible
until they don't need
to listen to me and then
I don't want them to listen to me at all.
More importantly, listen
to me, this is binary.
You need to act, if you
actually, if you use this time
that we've interacted,
this time, to understand
that any level of self
doubt or insecurity that you
have in your head is literally
been put inside of it
and it's not you doing
it to you, it will change
your fucking young life.
Are orders coming in?
All right, here we go.
Hold on, let me, this is important
because you know what it is?
I (meow) foot around it.
People haven't been able to
buy wine from winelebrity
for a decade in Illinois, no
fucking noise in Illinois,
Illinois (record scratch)
- [Devin On Phone] Wow, I knew
it was going to happen today.
- You felt it?
- [Devin] Holy shit.
- You felt it.
What up dude?
- Dude, my name is Devin.
I knew this was gonna
happen today, holy shit.
You know how sometimes
like you might you need,
you need the pick me up cuz it's hard.
- Two things, two things, I, no shit.
Of course it's hard,
especially when you're built
in a framework where you
value outside opinion.
One other thing, based on
you knowing that I was going
to call you today, just a
random gut feeling what the
pick six lotto might be.
Just gimme six numbers
real quick, go ahead.
- 32
- 32, right this down.
32, I'm gonna tweet out these numbers.
- 32, 36, because of Wutang
- 36, I love it.
- Zero five, because of you.
- Five, beautiful.
- And 20, wait
- 20, that's four we're
good we need two more
- Okay, two more?
20 and nine, six
- Nine and six
so five, six, nine, 20, 32 and 36?
Beautiful.
- Say it one more time for me
- You got it, you gonna go play it?
Dude if you fucking win the lottery today
I'm gonna lose my shit.
- Dude get the tickets,
we're both gonna win.
- Dude I'm 100% getting this
I expect all 3000 people,
how many are there?
About 800?
All right I expect all 4000 people
imagine it hits
if tomorrow I wake up and
there's a 5, 6, 9, 20, 32, 36
pick six somewhere, I'm gonna lose my shit
and so is somebody's who's
watching when it hits an organ
and they'll be like fuck
(laughter)
I love you man
all right just drop, keep doing it
let's go
this bruh was fired up I'm glad I did that
(deep bass music)
all right some of these are
if this fucking lottery
number hits somewhere
hey guys, thank you so
much for watching my video
on YouTube I wanted to
jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project
for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at
all, or know anybody that
drinks wine at all, please go
to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription
whether it's a three pack
or whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole case
of each for the year.
If you drink 36 bottles of
wine a year or give away
36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.
(deep electronic music)